you know you're such activists and you
know how proud i am to be associated
with you but
you try to bring up a tough subject for
a lot of men i welcome your movement
so that guys aren't so ashamed of their
small dongs
yeah i mean we were just trying to go on
you know on a big platform and just be
honest about our little hogs
and you know apparently it's uncouth to
talk about your dong on fox or maybe the
fact that
we talked about small dongs made it even
worse so
we have small dongs yes there's an
epidemic of dudes out there who feel bad
about their wieners
and dudes you don't have to i have a
small dong
and it's dang guys you can't stand live
shows and
talk about your dongs you can't do it
yeah
but what was your point since you
couldn't get it out on fox news
yeah i mean we're just trying to fight
small donk shame you know
because i think if we go out there and
we're like proud to have little hogs you
know it'll get more people streaking and
as you all know streaking boosts stoke
if we can just keep admitting it
on huge platforms like we're grateful to
you to say we have small dongs on the
platform then
you know smaller youtube dude oh
not not inverted but you know it's uh
i don't want to say thumbtack but it's
close
[Music]
you're not i'm ashamed i'm ashamed i'm
fired up on it dude
yeah have you dudes ever seen that
statue of that david guy
do you ever say hey he didn't have a big
dong and girls seem to like him
uh most the zhong pieces in antiquities
and in sculpture
super tiny and i think it makes it more
elegant so
yeah i'm fired up on old art and the way
that they were kind of modeling what a
beautiful penis looked like
have you guys ever had like a boner
fight between the two of you
oh dude i mean yeah but not to death
it's always like just like we're just
messing around who is smaller
between chad and jt if you don't mind me
asking
oh did we fight over this non-stop yeah
i don't know i think i'm smaller for
sure
oh i think i'm smaller get out of here
dude
are you sorry i mean sorry to beef with
you on air but
i don't know the shapes are different
like mine's more missile and his is more
mushroom
and then you know there's different ways
to measure
the size of it but i mean you know
either way we both have
little beautiful peckers yeah you got
small balls too
anybody have really big balls and no
deck uh
dude i'm proud to say jt has huge balls
wow
good for you come on man thank you yeah
that's so nice dude